the Metropolitan Police have named the
four people found dead at a house in
Hounslow on Friday
39 year old Michael vlogic who's a 35
year old Monica vladder Jack and 11 year
old Maya vladder Jack as well as
three-year-old
davidjerk now murder detectives are
heading the investigation but no one
else is currently being sought in
connection with the incident well let's
cross live now to our correspondence
Ivor Bennett who's in The Newsroom for
us now either what more can you tell us
yeah this is a statement that's come
through in the last few moments from the
Metropolitan Police they still don't
know the exact circumstances to that led
to the the deaths of these four people
and all of whom they believed to be
related obviously they all share the
same surname if their belief is correct
they say formal identification is yet to
take place these four people whose
bodies were discovered yesterday
afternoon at this flat in hounds though
in West London
um are Michael to check Monica have lot
of chick there age 39 and 35
respectively and two children Maya aged
11 David age three and and this is a
photo of uh the four as I say police
believe all four are to be are related
um their investigation continues at the
property as I say this is a flat it's an
upstairs flat uh in Hounslow in West
London forensic investigators specialist
officers have been coming and going
there Gathering evidence taking it away
as they try to piece together what led
to these four people's death yesterday
the investigation is being led by
murdered detectives but the person
leading that inquiry the chief
superintendent they've spoken to the
media this afternoon and said that at
this stage in their inquiry they're not
seeking anyone else in relation to this
incident they
are um still at the early stages of
trying to piece together exactly what
happened but they do believe all four
are related
um they were called at the property uh
to the property yesterday afternoon just
after 3 P.M after concerns were raised
for the family's well-being they had to
force entry and that's when they made
the discovery of the four bodies inside
and these are the people on the screen
who have been named Who police believe
uh have have been discovered there
obviously it's been a very upsetting
episode for all those living in the
local area and down at the scene this
afternoon we spoke to a number of
residents and neighbors who spoke of
their shock and distress at the events
that had happened there in the last 24
hours a lot of people starting to lay
flowers there and police have said that
officers will remain on the scene in the
local area throughout the weekend so
that
members of the community community can
feel reassured but also can approach
them were they any information that they
might have that might Aid their
investigation because as I say they're
still they still don't know exactly what
led to these four deaths but they now
say they have informed the families next
of kin and formal identification and a
post-mortem of the bodies will be
conducted in the near future